the aclu just just filed a lawsuit to
stop trump
from challenging these ballots so think
about what that means
that means in the future a court can
order it is a violation of the law to to
do what you're doing and they can say
too bad too bad we're we're allowed to
do it
no integrity no election security we're
allowed to do it this is what aclu is
arguing basically
the aclu is arguing that these ballots
should count
right even though they violated the
court order right i haven't seen the
full
paperwork right up but they tweeted
don't trust a single word you hear from
aclu man they lost
they lost it years ago when i got doxed
and i got fired for what i had written i
was contacted by the dc
head legal for aclu he says i want to
take your case
i want to take your case i want to help
you they violated your first amendment
right
he worked with me for months we wrote a
paper we did research we got everything
all the way through
he took it to his legal committee they
declined it he took it to the head
committee they declined it also and the
reason why they declined it despite the
fact the legal director of the aclu said
it was a clear violation of my first
amendment rights because they didn't
want to offend
their coalition partners such as human
rights campaign
black lives matter exactly now on what
you're talking about here i think one
thing that we've learned
about uh how to get at your enemies and
how to win
what did they do to mike flynn they
didn't get mike flynn on any real crimes
would they get mike flynn process
process crimes everybody makes mistakes
in process so it makes some good sense
actually to attack the election from a
process
standpoint so it will be interesting to
see how that
plays out man i i'm not a lawyer and the
question that i want to have answered
especially after i talked to matt
brainard yesterday is
let's say that there are you know five
people in every important district that
come forth with a sworn affidavit
saying their fraud their vote was you
know somehow invalidated or fraud or
there's something going on there
what then how many instances do there
have to be
and then what is the recourse you know
what if everybody says
okay yeah we swear that we saw this
fraud happening we saw this happening
what do they do they they do a re-vote
no no why not they have to do it by
december
11th right december 11th december 14th
is the electoral college vote there you
go
boom yeah okay so make an amendment when
two-thirds of the states ratify it in in
two or three years
right the amendment process in this
country it took a really long time
i think it was the 17th amendment it was
like seven or eight years before they
actually
fully implemented it after it was
already ratified by all these different
states so so if the vote's fraudulent
or we can't do a re-vote no
it goes to the house there's a process
they just decide it's already been
decided in advance when you enter in the
rules of the game the rules of the game
say
in the event in the event of this house
delegations vote
so there's there's a bunch of other
really weird things
about like it could potentially go to
kamala harris there's one uh provision i
haven't read enough about it
that if they can't determine you know
certify the president-elect then they'll
try to certify the vice president-elect
or something
i don't know the full details on it but
yeah maybe kamala harris i don't know
dude okay
i tweeted out a couple years ago i said
very clearly
kamala harris will never be president
comma i know
i knew you were going to stop me because
you have it it's what they said right
kamala harris will never be president
and i know that i've said it it's out
there people screen cap it fine
i think about deleting that tweet all
the time and it's like it's good it's
going to go down i'm going to get a
friend it could go down
as the worst take in my entire embracing
life
there's no avoiding it ever look true
at a pressure please no exactly about a
cath care exactly
i i i can't exactly it's we're already
seeing people
are looking at the election without
actual evidence and they're like i don't
believe this and i think that's scary
seeing tweets from like tariq nasheed
you see what he's talking about
you know who he is right yeah he's like
this is a finesse he's like i'm not a
trump supporter but there's no way come
on
he's like how how could joe biden beat
barack obama's
you know uh record by like 10 million
or by like 7 million votes or whatever
oh it's eight million now
joe biden beat barack obama by eight
million votes
so you've got people who love obama and
they're saying
bs no way no way you beat obama
right i'm not saying joe biden couldn't
people hate trump
i think i think it makes sense and i
think right now
this is what was what vox said it's
really funny they're starting to write
these articles because
they're not free these these writers are
not free to tell you what's really going
on
they're worried about offending their
audience they're worried about what
their bosses will say
i got nothing to worry about i say i
mean i'm worried about you know
if we if we swear too much an
unnecessary de-ranking of content
but i'll talk about all this stuff even
even if it risks me getting banned or
whatever
i don't have to go check with my boss i
can say straight up
there is a slim possibility that donald
trump pulls this off
based on the arguments we're hearing the
amount of states he'd have to flip
but if he gets a 14th amendment argument
to the supreme court and it works it
would nullify many male and
mainland ballots in a ton of states and
that would probably that would probably
seal the deal well we saw what happened
tuesday night versus wednesday morning
that would seal the deal right right
exactly
yeah wow so so the landslide many of
these
but here's the thing many of these are
absentee the issue is
will the supreme court agree now i don't
know what i do know
is that there are three members of the
supreme court who helped george bush win
in 2000 roberts kavanaugh and amy coney
barrett
and that when i heard that i i someone
super chatted it and i was like
no way there's no way trump appointed
two
of the bush lawyers yep he did and then
and then get this
clarence thomas you think he's got a
bone to pick with john oh man
go back to the 90s and watch those
videos if you haven't seen it dude do
you see what clarence thomas said to joe
biden no
90s oh my god i can't repeat what he
said whoa he said
it was i'll give you the jesse said it
was a what what did he call it uh a
high-tech lynch a high-tech lynching
cyber lynching something for company
not cybers yeah yup because i said that
to who
clear stuff clarence thomas when they
were accusing him of what was it like
sexual assault or something yep
harassment harassment he was they were
he was nominated for the supreme court
and that they ran him through the coals
accusing him of being this
harasser and he said it was it was
essentially a lynching to stop
uppity blacks that's what clarence
thomas thomas said
and so now there's a meme going around
of clarence thomas with his eyes glowing
and it says i've been waiting 30 years
for this moment joe
i believe that would impugn the honor of
clarence thomas though i think he can
rule
impartially aside he can roll on the
merits
what about kavanaugh you don't think
he's got a bone to pick dude with guess
who
k harris she was one of the worst in
those
hearings i watched every second and he
was on the verge of
i was crying in my house on my couch
watching him it was mostly when he
started talking about how he got
he couldn't coach his girls his
daughter's basketball team anymore
because of all this nonsense and i had
recently just lost my
little league with my son so it really
hit home for me but i'll never forget
that moment because that's when i really
saw
evil evil yeah and i saw and i saw the
language of
radical feminism and intersectionality
and critical race theory all coming out
of the mouths of these senators
at a hearing for a supreme court justice
and that was the moment that i knew
that the culture war that i had been
observing for 10 years was not just some
crazy tinfoil thing
it had made it all the way into
judiciary hearings like confirmation
of this of the supreme court justice and
it was
just terrifying to me so if anybody
remembers
how much of a b k harris can be
it is brett kavanaugh i think you just
need to remember the face
that brett kavanaugh had made when he
was nearly in tears
and his wife was was was nearly in tears
watching it happen
this is a guy who was already vetted to
be on the courts when he became a
federal judge they vetted him
they were going through it again they
were digging through his yearbook they
were digging through his
calendar from high school you drink beer
what does that mean and they were
berating him
and implying on tv that he was he was
part of a group that would line up
outside of bedrooms and drug women and
take turns if you know what i mean
and that is insane yeah the the
accusations the people banging on the
door
screaming i got to be honest i think
after 30 years maybe clarence thomas is
like
ah it's been 30 years brett kavanaugh's
like that was
a year and a half ago yeah it was two
years i think whatever happens they're
gonna
stick to the letter of the law like if
that means that trump has them on a
technicality i think they'll rule in
trump's favor yep
i agree it's not it's not so much about
a technicality it's about
so uh it's interestingly we're seeing
the media's desperate attempt to sweep
this under the rug there was a tweet
from some some journalists saying
trump flat out admits it or something
and it's a transcript from one of the
lawsuits where they were like
the judge asked them point blank if they
were fraud and they said
no and then all these lefties are
high-fiving each other that's an attempt
to trick people into thinking trump's
lying
the lawsuit was about improper ballots
not fraud
so the judge said i'm asking you right
now was there fraud and the lawyer said
to my to my knowledge
no they're trying to make it seem the
second part of that
was confusing because it said is there
impropriety in the voting and it also
said no
because right because what he's arguing
is these people
made a mistake their ballots don't count
and so the point i'm bringing up is
technicalities
it doesn't matter it's a technicality
what matters is the argument from the
lawyer was
it's in the the the legal code we must
adhere to the legal code
you're going to hear a different opinion
from different people as to why it's an
illegal code
doesn't matter it's in there for a
reason is he is he arguing a
no is he arguing b no and then they
stopped but what he was arguing with c
was also it was also a problem no he
says this he just didn't even ask him
about if that's what he was doing
you must have missed the page of the
transcript he says it he says it's in
i did miss the page yeah he says it's in
the code and for whatever reason we can
speculate
it's it's in the code he he basically
said
you can ask me why it's there you can
ask me why i think this violation
warrants its qualification and it's
irrelevant
the law says without this disqualified
and he's correct
it's not it's not up to the to the uh to
us to determine
the intent it's like here's the law
here's here's what it says about the
bouts and how they're supposed to be
processed if you don't do it that
doesn't matter so fraud's a specific
legal term oh yeah fraud is deception
we're talking about people who just want
to be clear people who didn't put their
addresses on the ballots
i see so the ballots are trash okay yeah
that's what that particular
okay so where i'm at is plug in a couple
holes of the dam
i think that's the what side i'm on the
metaphor but i'm not gonna stand there
and get blasted by a rush of water if it
looks like
it's not gonna work i'm not gonna keep
screaming to to
make sure biden fails and that we got to
go after hammer and school we got to
find
i'm just going to say if it doesn't work
i'm i'm i'm bowing out and i'm focusing
on the solution for the next election
which i think is online
there won't be a next election oh there
will be another election but listen
if if they can legally violate a court
if they can violate a court order and
get away with it
you think someone's going to be able to
win legitimately next time if
if they if yeah yeah how well legitimate
it's a loaded term right now they they
violated a court firstly that is a big
if
if they if they pull off some nonsense
that's a big
problem so so right now let's say that
trump goes to court and says
they violated the court order and
counted these ballots and now because
they've already been removed from the
envelopes
we can't reverse the process and observe
so you think
if the letter if the law is upheld right
now that trump will win
i don't know like are you saying that if
from what you see you're saying such a
court order
yeah from what you see the court agrees
with trump so here's the problem
first of all assuming it's true they
counted 450 000 ballots that's the
statement from the legal from the legal
team
just because they followed the lawsuit
doesn't mean it would happen assuming
that's the case
we do know what's true is they counted
without observers being able to watch
within the distance uh uh the court
system confirmed because there's videos
of people there with binoculars saying
they won't let us pass
this barricade and they're 100 feet from
us the court said six
we don't know what the number is here's
the problem
if the court says we don't care they
violated the court order
these ballots are good you incentivize
legit fraud
because now everyone's like we could we
could we could shuffle in a bunch of
boxes and count them and they won't do
anything about it
done if they do stop it there's also a
problem
if they say these ballots are spoiled
then you could create a situation
where you trick people into destroying
ballots on accident how would you do
that
so you get people to open the ballots
without an observer
then you file a suit saying you see what
i mean
that one's more circuitous so ultimately
i err on the side of
if the ballots were counted within
violation of a court order
you can't count them you can't we
we have a security process and a legal
observation process
a public observation process for a
reason individuals can walk in and watch
because we want to make sure there's an
integrity and we're being honest
if somebody is is doing something in
secret when it's supposed to be for the
public
the public has a right to know what
they're doing with our resources we have
foia right the freedom of information
act
we can request the government give us
documents on things and then they argue
why they should or shouldn't and then
they redact stuff and then they give it
out
when it comes to our elections we need
to know that we can watch publicly
that's what i was suggesting earlier
maybe the vote tallies are up here
online the only problem with that is you
need an internet connection on these
machines and that could be
you know problematic but i think a lot
of the data was published online in
increments from various
uh outlets the ultimately what i'm
saying is
we wouldn't need uh observers if as soon
as someone put the ballot in
it appeared boom like here's the vote
here's the person who's here's what it's
for
the problem is bouts are secret you know
for a reason
people wouldn't vote for trump if bats
were public they'd be terrified
no everyone would find out so they won't
be nice if you didn't see what the vote
was
for but all the information was public
like the social security number was
published no
no no no no no no everyone's social
security is public no
it's like it's just your your dog people
know what your number is you know
lifelock
yeah the like identity theft he did that
commercial where he had a truck driving
off the social security number on it and
he was like i'm safe and then he got his
identity stolen like 14 times
because you're not you can't everyone is
going to be able to keep their social
security number secret in this world
yeah but you know might as well just use
that
that we can use for some criminals can
figure out your security number so we
might as well publish everyone well
we've got to use a personal id code
along with a barcode that shows who you
voted for and only you can scan that
or we just who the vote was for ian
actually makes a good
point here in that all information will
become known eventually
like our network the whole way that our
society is going
all information is going to end up being
public right you can't
you know rely on anonymity you can't
rely on things being said in secret
you know if you're secure enough now you
should start preparing yourself for the
idea that all information is going to be
publicly known
they may not be now but it's coming use
a password manager
bit warden is a good one um it's it's
open source software and it keeps your
encrypted password
uh you need a master password to log
into it better than keeping your
passwords unlike your browser
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you